make an impression when you when you
enter people's lives you make an
impression caitlyn do you remember the
first time you met danny what was that
experience like yeah these guys had
already met with him and uh i was coming
on set
and danny's first scene was with me
where he's trying to [ __ ] me out to a
politician so
he's got me all dressed up at that old
sitcom yeah that old thing
that thing you've seen a million times
before um so i'm dressed like a [ __ ]
and i i i say hi mr devito my name's
caitlin i'm so pleased to meet you and
he goes yeah yeah pull those boobies out
some more
you got to get those boobs up pull them
out more people they'll like that
they'll like it and i was like
i'm wearing my mic if the sound man can
hear me i believe i'm in danger
he was in character but he forgot oh
that was your that was your character
yeah it was my husband character sure
okay and then that's your i bet that's
excuse that's your excuse a lot of the
time i know yeah
character we did the entire scene yeah i
don't think i looked at her face once
yeah yeah
isn't that which character are you in
now yeah
do you ever tell do you ever say i'm in
k i was in character your honor
we know that's coming yeah it hasn't
happened yet yeah yeah
uh guys do you remember the first things
that's a big decision you bring uh danny
devito onto the show do you remember
your first meeting with him oh yeah yeah
we went to lunch in beverly hills and he
immediately sits down and tells us about
a box that his father has that's full of
teeth
and watches and you came in like a
tornado uh much like what you're
experiencing
like i came in and told you that my
father had a box of teeth yesterday like
you were sitting at a table and you were
we were late you're running late i was
late and you came firing in like a like
a firecracker right he sat down and we
were like i was
kind of similar to this yeah but like
hey it's so great to meet you man you
were in character you were in character
but we didn't know that but you didn't
know what the character was and yeah we
had an establishment you proceeded to
order uh food for everyone you know
regardless of what we may or may not eat
yeah yeah
oh you were you thought you were in get
shorty yeah
that's what it was and then that's
exactly what it was and then you left
and we were like uh our tv show's going
to be ruined yes
you know a bunk fired a madman so he he
runs in he says all this madness your
father had a box full of teeth
and watches and watches i don't even
want to know
forget it i i think i think i might okay
but i think i might have been
bullshitting about that
yeah i thought it was a good thing you
know yeah you never met these that's
always before my father's got a box full
of teeth yeah i mean you're not gonna
forget this guy right right
fantastic so uh
so he tells you that and then you leave
did you actually have second thoughts at
that point yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
once we
we finished crying we were like all
right good run we're like what if the
character is like a guy with a box full
of teeth and watches and you know that's
sort of what you became
we we've never done a teeth show with
wherever no but it's the spirit of what
you are in this show it's the spirit of
saving teeth yeah we're only halfway
through our lives
is how the creative process works for
for all of you around oh they're
absolutely nuts i swear to god no no no
danny we know who's crazy here
we have this all on tape we can review
it with you
a circle at play-by-play you're here's
where you went nuts here's where no one
could follow you yeah here's where no
one else we've got a transcript and
everything there's no getting out of
this now teeth and
what we moved on from now okay okay and
it was a lie
you keep bringing us back to it and it
turns out there has no basis in reality
he's gonna go home and check his clothes
i gotta go see if there's anywhere
let's get through a day of shooting with
him seriously how do you get through a
day of shooting you've got to drink
through this i don't know
how do you you have to do takes you have
to you know you have to get it right
eventually our time will run out and
that will be the end
you got what you got you cut it together
an episode i mean if he had boxes of tv